le cap des dix mille contaminé a été
franchie aujourd'hui quasiment donc onze
mille cas confirmés par test 108
personnes de plus ont succombé à la
maladie le personnel hospitalier est
tabou mais tente de faire face malgré un
manque de moyens un manque de masques
sur tous les services sont saturés le
pays se prépare donc est la priorisation
de soins coûtent et nous avons une
épidémie qui s'étend et une épidémie qui
continue à s'aggraver avec une
circulation virale rapide et intense
dans de nombreuses zones du territoire
national nous allons donc devoir
affronter une épidémie importante dans
ces prochains jours avec évidemment des
incertitudes sur le comportement du
virus lui-même mais surtout nous devons
tout faire pour que les mesures
barrières individuelles et collectives
soient les plus efficaces possibles donc
réduire massivement tous nos contacts
aujourd'hui nous avons dit 1995 cas
confirmés par test pcr
parmi ces personnes quatre mille quatre
cent soixante et une personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisées
ce qui veut dire que 5000 personnes sont
à domicile confiné parmi les personnes
hospitalisées
on recense 1122 cas graves en
réanimation mais aussi près de 1300
retour à domicile de personnes guéries
le nombre de cas double tous les quatre
jours toutes les régions métropolitaines
et les territoires ultramarins sont
concernés les six régions les plus
touchées sont toujours les mêmes la
corse le grand est
l'île de france la bourgogne franche
comté les hauts de france et l'auvergne
rhône-alpes
on observe des formes graves
essentiellement chez des adultes avec
une médiane à 60 en réanimation dont 50%
des cas ont moins de 60 ans et
malheureusement on déplore 372 décès
dont 6 % chez des moins de 60 ans la
crise sanitaire pourrait entraîner
jusqu'à 25 millions de pertes d'emploi
au niveau mondial selon une première
estimation de l'organisation
internationale du travail
emmanuel macron
encourage les entreprises à poursuivre
leurs activités dans le respect des
règles de sécurité sanitaire la mitis
travail elle a informé que la priorité
du gouvernement était de protéger les
salariés
ce qui n'est pas interdit est autorisé
en matière de travail et là je voudrais
faire prendre conscience tout le monde
que nous sommes très interdépendants
pour la santé et tous en soutien et
soignants qui sont au front au front de
cette guerre et que derrière à l'arrière
quand on dit en langage de guerre il
faut aussi que les activités continuent
les français ils ont besoin de produits
alimentaires de produits de nettoyage
ils ont besoin d'internet pour l'école à
la maison et pour le télétravail
ils ont besoin d'électricité ils ont
besoin de transport je vais pas faire la
longue liste mais quand vous regardez de
bout en bout
il n'y a pas de métier qu'ils soient
inutiles à la nation il n'est pas
question de mettre en danger la
protection des salariés
la première priorité c'est de
sauvegarder l'emploi c'est pour ça que
nous faisons un plan de chômage partiel
parce massif comme on n'a jamais fait en
france c'est ainsi que nous rendrons à
la fois la vie quotidienne possible pour
les français
nous protégerons les salariés et que
nous serons repartir avec les
compétences nécessaires demain quand la
crise sera terminée mais le projet de la
loi d'urgence sanitaire a été débattu
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale en
comité restreint
pour en parler nous retrouvons sur place
notre reporter il a faim à mouzon
bonsoir l'île afin quelles mesures
d'urgence ont été votées à l'assemblée
alors bon soir stéphanie plusieurs
mesures d'urgence évoqué ce matin lors
d'une séance de questions au
gouvernement dans une ambiance assez
étranger dans un hémicycle presque vide
alors une petite anecdote qui illustre
l'ambiance étrange qu'il y avait ce
matin au palais bourbon
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie agnès pannier-runacher a
été prise d'une quinte de toux une
quinte de toux qui a été accueilli par
des sourires crispés dans un silence
assez inquiétant ça vous montre à quel
point cette séance ce matin était assez
particulière et puis comme on pouvait
s'y attendre toutes les questions
portait évidemment sur la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire sans précédent
avec notamment
la question des masques qui est revenu
plusieurs fois le premier ministre a été
interpellé à plusieurs reprises par tous
les groupes présents ici à l'assemblée
nationale aussi bien les socialistes que
les républicains olivier ferrand a tenté
de déminer la polémique sur le manque de
matériel en pointant du doigt une
décision des gouvernements précédents et
puis un peu plus tard matt hill panneau
du groupe
elle est fille a demandé la création
d'un comité parlementaire de suivi
permanent pour dit-elle eu plus de
transparence dans l'action du
gouvernement dans la gestion de cette
crise alors ensuite cette séance de
questions au gouvernement à zurich et a
duré à peu près une heure et demie a été
suivie dans l'après midi par une séance
cette fois ci pour examiner le projet de
loi de finances rectificative pardon le
gouvernement a annoncé qu'ils allaient
intégrer un plan de soutien de 45,1
milliards d'euros une première mesure
qui sera le report des charges fiscales
et sociales pour toutes les entreprises
sur le mois de mars c'est la déclaration
de bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie il a également évoqué la
création d'un fonds de solidarité visant
à soutenir les plus petites entreprises
les indépendants et les
micro-entreprises alors le député
charles de courson du groupe liberté et
territoires a estimé que l'hypothèse
d'un confinement d'un mois était un peu
trop optimiste nicolas dupont aignan de
la france de 2000 à 2001 france pardon a
dénoncé quant à lui le manque
d'anticipation du gouvernement dans
cette crise alors les débats se
poursuivent et les députés ont
semble-t-il voulu montrer en tout cas
aujourd'hui qu'il prenait à coeur à
cette crise qui frappe la france
aujourd'hui alors que le virus se
propage à grande vitesse merci dit la
fsa amouzou et le gouvernement français
qui décidons de ne pas procéder à des
tests systématiques du coronavirus en
tout cas pour l'instant une décision
contraire pourtant préconisations
récente de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
un choix du gouvernement
viserait à concentrer les efforts du
personnel soignant sur les populations à
risque une décision vivement critiquée
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui lors du débat sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et le docteur jérôme
marquis marty évoque justement ce manque
de moyens notamment la question de ces
tests pour gérer la crise sanitaire
actuelle c'est difficile quand on
examine des patients c'est difficile
quand on fait des soins il faut avec ce
qu'ils ont et ceux qu'ils ont c'est à la
fois leur courage leur professionnalisme
et puis un petit peu de matériel de
protection mais pas suffisant mais ils
se on va dire que pour l'instant
malheureusement il se débrouille pour
rappel quand même qu'il y a globalement
un million cinq cent mille
professionnels de santé donc 25 millions
de protection par rapport à un million
cinq cent mille ça fait quand même pas
le compte
il faut il faut qu'il y ait beaucoup
plus il faut que la france investisse
beaucoup plus dans la protection de ses
soignants parce que protéger ses
soignants ses protégés
ces patients est donc protégé les
français donc qu'ils ont on voit qu'on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de retard
quant à ces protections là il ya eu un
discours qui a été un peu erratique on a
cherché manifestement à cacher certaines
choses cachées certainement qu
aujourd'hui on sait que la france est en
manque de protection des productions des
terrans c'est aussi aujourd'hui que
l'industrie textile on avait demandé va
se mettre en mouvement pour constituer
donc d'aider des masques à la fois
chirurgicaux est probablement fsp 2
c'est ce qu'il fallait
il fallait certainement que les
entreprises françaises commencent à
produire sur le sur le territoire
national par rapport à un manque qui
était quelqu'un était lié à un manque
sans doute de préville de prévisibilité
aujourd'hui on voit que alors c'est là
où encore ont rejoint une communication
opératique puisque on a vu que on avait
annoncé comme phase iii ne testait paléo
le tester plus les patients et puis là
en face d'eux on avait les tests qui
était réservé à un usage hospitalier
là on a baissé le niveau d'exigence des
laboratoires pour que ces tests arrivent
en ville pour que les laboratoires de
ville puisse les faire mais avec une
doctrine qui disait on ne teste pas les
patients donc c'était assez confus
en fait on va tester certainement plus
de patients quand même symptomatique et
puis surtout surtout surtout ce qu'on
demande et qui nous paris
extrêmement important c'est le tester
tous les soignants dès l'instant où ils
sont asymptomatiques
la vague est toujours avec une espèce de
mosaïque sur le territoire elle descend
lentement mais elle risque de frapper et
de frapper fort
il va falloir que quelqu'un se prépare
et qu'on soit prêts qu'on soit prêt à
faire face la priorisation tout tout
tout là du tout l'idée de confiner les
gens c'est justement d'éviter que cette
diffusion est d'arriver à écrêter cette
courbe de façon à ce qu'on ne dépasse
pas nos capacités thérapeutique parce
qu'alors si on les dépasse et non
seulement on aurait évidemment à faire
des choix extrêmement difficile pour des
soignants qui est celle de 2,2 de
soigner ou pas telle ou telle patients
en tout cas en réanimation de ne pas
pousser la réanimation pour tel ou tel
patient mais on aurait également des
dommages collatéraux qui seraient liées
à toutes les autres pathologies tous les
autres patients qui relève également de
réanimation mais dès qu'on passe et son
grade ya que des combats soient
respiratoires les accidents de la route
etc tel pour évoquer cette crise nous
sommes avec le docteur bertron galichon
urgentiste à l'hôpital lariboisière
bonsoir bertrand et galichon merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
auger l'une de vos interviews vous êtes
firent mieux que un pic serait attendu
dans les deux trois jours en tout cas un
afflux de patients veuillez m'excuser
puisque les mots ont leur importance
vous pensez donc ça sera un afflux
important dans deux trois jours de
patients accueillis dans les hôpitaux
écoutez tous moi je suis à lariboisière
dont près des gares du nord à paris je
peux vous donner un témoignage à partir
de cet endroit
la semaine a été calme en moins d'une et
flux des patients arrivent aux urgences
mais on les a vus arriver de plus en
plus nombreux et surtout on essaie de
préparer de façon extrêmement active à
l'afflux que nous attendons pour ce week
end je peux pas vous dire si ça sera
demain matin ou dimanche matin
mais on
voilà on est certain que là on va avoir
un afflux de deux personnes susceptibles
d'être touchés par le virus
important pour quelle raison ce
sentiment vous avez laissé les chiffres
épidémiologique c'est l'évolution des
courbes que l'on voit arriver depuis le
depuis grand un ski qui a été touché
avant nous on voit bien les chiffres qui
doublent très régulièrement toutes les
48 heures on aurait bien qu'on voit être
devant un pic très important dans les
prochains jours ou début de semaine
prochaine
ça veut dire que ce sont des personnes
nouvellement contaminées qui alors que
les les mesures de confinement n'était
pas encore mises en oeuvre et qui se
seraient contaminés justement en étant
un petit peu insouciant il y a quelques
jours de cela alors il ya le bief acquis
entre ligne de compte
il ya aussi les gens qui ont été
contaminés qui se sont petit s'aggrave
et qui va falloir prendre en charge et
qui sont encore chez elle et puis à des
nouveaux qu'un parce que je pense pas
que les mesures que nous aimions prise
de confinement et c'est totalement
hermétique
c'est à dire vous pensez qu'à un
confinement plus stricts seraient
souhaitables aujourd'hui alors je pense
pas qu'on puisse aller raisonnablement
beaucoup plus loin sinon que nous mètres
carrés seront tous sur une sous cloche
je crois que ce qui est fait raisonnable
au ce matin j'ai pris j'ai pris le métro
et puis nous étions deux dans la rame de
métro à une heure où normalement nous
sommes nous sommes restés sans elle je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse aller plus
loin on entendait le témoignage d'un
médecin français qui se trouvent en
chine le docteur philip laing ce
témoignage a été publié par de nombreux
médias français qui en gros 10 et voilà
si on ne fait pas comme les chinois si
on ne respecte pas des mesures
absolument drastiques
le bilan pourrait être terrible encore
plus lourd vous ne partagez pas ce
diagnostic de votre confrère français
qui se trouvent à ouman précisément
alors je pense qu'il faut il faut gérer
la crise au jour le jour en anticipant
sa montée de certaines il faut tenir
compte des différences de culture entre
l'asie et l'europe l'asie et très et
culturellement très structurée par le
groupe alors que nous ne sommes plus le
structurer ou sur la personne de l'année
début donc les choses sont complètement
différentes la gestion n'est pas la même
nos origines politiques ne sont pas les
mêmes donc la gestion ne peut pas être
ou ne pas être
d'autre part je crois que il ne faut pas
rajouter un sur accident à l'accident
initial
je crois que tout le mouvement de
panique serait extrêmement délétère
qu'il était très en armes
je pense qu'il faut tenir compte des
deux principes de précaution et puis
celui d' incertitudes parce qu'on est
devant quelque chose de tout à fait
nouveau
enfin au moins pour notre notre
génération je pense qu'il faut garder
garder son calme et je pense à l'heure
actuelle en l'europe
enfin au moins france et choses semblent
être gérée de façon correcte en fonction
de ce que l'on sait est-ce que l'une des
solutions pour vous passera par
davantage de tests comme l'ont fait
certains pays asiatiques
alors moi je pense que c'est
effectivement les solutions une seule
sur un cas récent tu sais qu'il faut que
les tests soient sérologique soi et les
prélèvements naso soit soit diffusée
plus largement
et puis je crois qu'il faut aussi que
nous puissions alors c'est travailler
maintenant au niveau de l'hôpital
trouver les tests radiologiques s'en
verrait tout ça qui puisse nous
permettre plus facilement le confirmer
ou d'infirmer la gravité de nos patients
touchés par le corps non violent
merci beaucoup docteur bertrand guay
michon d'avoir été en direct avec nous
sur rt france merci à vous et surtout
bon courage dans votre mission et le
gouvernement français qui reconnaît un
manque de masque on parlait de manque de
moyens tout à l'heure le ministre de la
santé olivier vers en appel ce matin
utiliser les masques avec parcimonie il
assure cependant que près de 30 millions
de masques ont tété déstocker et livrés
depuis trois jours au personnel de santé
edouard philippe assure que seuls les
professionnels de la santé devrait être
privilégiée j'ai compris de ce que
disent les autorités de santé que le
port du masque en population générale
n'était pas recommandé il n'est pas
recommandé d'abord parce que l'utilité
du port du masque en population générale
autrement dit lorsqu'on se promène dans
la rue lorsque on respecte les gestes
barrière lorsqu'on respecte les
distances de sécurité
il n'est pas recommandé car il est
inutile et qu'il prive ceux qui ont
besoin des masques parce que leurs
activités les places dans des situations
qui ne sont pas celles de la population
générale
les soignants bien entendu tous ceux qui
sont directement au contact des malades
ou les malades eux mêmes déclaré
afin de limiter la propagation du virus
un grand nombre de professionnels de
santé ont pu depuis deux jours à les
voir leurs officines pourra pour prendre
des masques avec une logique de
rationnement qui a été présenté à chaque
syndicat à chaque corporation et
j'ajoute part dans ce présent qui lie à
17 millions de masques qui ont également
été livrés depuis hier soir
aujourd'hui et demain à l'ensemble des
hôpitaux des grosses des groupement
hospitalier de territoire des ehpad et
des organismes de transports sanitaires
de notre pays ce qui fait au total près
de 30 millions de masques qui ont été
déstocker et livrés depuis maintenant
trois jours et face au manque de masquer
une marque française d'espadrilles fait
preuve de solidarité et on fabrique pour
en parler
donc ça vous avec olivier gély fondateur
de paillotes bonsoir olivier gély merci
en direct sur la séquence vous êtes donc
le patron de cette petite pme passé à
perpignan qui d'ordinaire fabrique des
espadrilles made in france est là avec
cette crise et bien vous avez décidé de
faire preuve de solidarité très briquet
ce dont les français manquent
cruellement et surtout les soignants des
masques de protection expliquez-nous
votre démarche et comment vous avez eu
l'idée en fait c'était j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui sont infirmiers et qui m'ont
raconté en fait là la pénurie de masques
qui avait au sein des du corps médical
et on s'est dit pourquoi pas c'est
pourquoi pas faire un bénin toile
l'espadrille de les chutes qui nous
reste est de faire des masques pour mais
ceux qui ne sont pas aux normes et
homologué de faire des masques peut-être
qui pourrait rassurer les patients et
peut-être aussi apporté un petit peu de
gaieté dans dans cette période un peu
difficile
donc on s'est mis on a travaillé sur un
patron qu'on a travaillé aussi en amont
avec avec le personnel et c'est là qu'on
s'est dit bon ben il va falloir qu'on
s'organise pour fabriquer avec nos
toiles le maximum de masques pour qu'on
puisse livrer à tous à tout le corps
médical et les aides soignants les les
aides à domicile les infirmiers on a eu
des appels de partout on a vraiment dans
toute la france et là c'est vrai c'est
là qu'on a pu on a pu ressentir en fait
le le la détresse de tout le corps
médical
ç'a vraiment été une surprise pour nous
et on s'attendait pas tout ce à quoi
donc ça vraiment donc on s'est mis en
place
on a organisé on a fait appel à des
couturières des couturiers on a eu je
crois qu'on a eu peut-être une centaine
d'appels de dire dans ma région
donc pour vraiment vraiment de tout âge
de temps des jeunes de 20 ans qui
apprenaient à coudre à autant des
personnes plus âgées qui me disaient
voilà je suis au les jeux
puis je ne fais rien de la journée
est-ce que vous pouvez m'apporter des
toiles et puis pour je puisse fabriquer
les masques et donc à voir près c'est
vrai que par rapport à la livraison
c'est un peu compliqué de s'organiser
c'est là qu'on s'est dit pas comment on
pourrait faire m m en passe ou ça et
comme on avait à faire quand même pas
mal d'ambulanciers qui venait chercher
des masques pour l'hormadi
est-ce que vous pouvez nous aider ils
nous ont répondu il n'y a pas de souci
pendant deux heures de temps de repos
vous nous donnez la toile on l'amène
aura directement aux personnes qui sont
à domicile pour fabriquer les masques et
on voulait ramènera pour les données
pour les donner aux corps médical comme
il sait vraiment combien de de masques
vous avez arriver à produire par jour et
comment vous arrivez à l'est à les
distribuer donc on a mis en place on
s'est organisé depuis mardi
donc ça a été ça n'a pas été facile
parce que du coup c'est pas trop notre
corps de métier les masques et donc à
partir de mardi midi quand la bien
travail sur le patron on a commencé à
produire et là on à peu près à 1500 mah
ce que aujourd'hui en l'espace de deux
jours donc ça le problème c'est la main
d'oeuvre donc du coup on a la toile il
ya un moment tu sens je pense que dans
deux jours on aura on sera en manque de
toiles manque de manque de tout ce qui
est issu manque de d'élastiques donc ça
va être nous après on arrive et on sera
en pénurie de mais on aura fait voilà
notre petite action on va essayer
d'aider au mastic maximum où on en était
les solidaires avec tout avec tout le
monde les infirmiers voilà et pour les
passer du coup perd on était il y avait
une personne qui tu es en bas et qui
voilà donc avec les gants le masque et
du coup on passait au aux personnes qui
venaient nous chercher
mais sur tout le corps médical qui
venait me chercher directement en bas de
notre immeuble donc mais je voyais la
détresse dans les yeux qui me disaient
voilà moi je passe ça fait des journées
je suis avec eux des mouchoirs de jj
voilà je les jeux les larges même jour
on sait que ça ne sera peut-être pas à
rien mais
et c'est pas grave on le met sur notre
visage ça nous rassure ça rassure les
patients et voilà c'était c'était le but
donc nous après c'est vrai qu'on n'est
pas on n'est pas voilà on fabrique pas
des masques homologué ça c'est sûr si ça
peut redonner le sourire ça peut aussi
rassurer les patients c'est avec plaisir
qu'on a fait ça et voilà les masses qui
sont étaient gratuits on a on les a
offerts donc voilà c'est vraiment
c'était vraiment un acte de ce slut
solidarité j'ai vu que quand même mais
l'initiative on espère quand même qu'ils
sont efficaces en vous l'avez dit
vous-même non homologué mais en tout cas
l'initiative est belle et les couleurs
de vos masques sont belles aussi et
redonne peut-être le sourire une chose
est sûre c'est depuis l'annnonce du
confinement les clients se sont rués de
sur les denrées non périssables dans les
supermarchés mais qu'en est il des
marchés locaux à bordeaux zoom sur un de
ces marchés couverts avec stéphanie joie
et cyrielle bruit
des commerçants esseulé une place vide
et de ses clients habituels le marché
des capucins lieux incontournables situé
en plein coeur de bordeaux a perdu sa
chaleur confinement oblige les
commerçants s'organisent afin
d'accueillir les rares clients dans les
meilleures conditions possibles pouvoir
garder les distances de sécurité
nous-mêmes déjà de par la vitrine on a
au moins un mètre voire plus d'un mètre
et puis désinfecter tous les lieux nous
prat vers les clients nous travaillons
avec le masque
même si je ne vais pas là mais nous
travaillons avec le mas et les
affichages réglementaire que nous avons
disposé sur les vitrines sur les poteaux
un peu partout pour rappeler fréquemment
fréquemment et régulièrement les
conditions aux usagers aux clients je
suis en train de mettre des
délimitations pour que les gens
respectent les distances de sécurité qui
ont été demandés pour des gens
apprennent à garder ses distances des
mesures nécessaires qui entachent la
convivialité de ce marché couvert les
commerçants ont peur de ne pas pouvoir
écouler leurs stocks face à cette crise
sanitaire sans précédent
un premier bilan économique dramatique
pour les petits commerçants comme le
déplore georges mercadal représentant
régional du groupe géré aux exploitants
du marché des capucins économiquement
pour ceux qui ont pris le parti
effectivement de ne pas venir ben c'est
le chômage technique pour se
comme les points de restauration de ces
ya manque à gagner en termes de chiffre
d'affaires de toute évidence c'est pour
certains petits commerçants c'est ça
peut être dramatique dans leurs
résultats
en effet non sans goût une forme de pas
de panique mais un petit peu de
tristesse en tout cas nos tristesses sur
l'ensemble du marché même si les
commerçants encore une fois font tout et
où tant en termes d'approvisionnement
aussi que de bienveillance pour que le
marché continue à fonctionner une
ambiance morose particulièrement
soulignée par les rares clients qui
déambulent dans les allées du marché
c'est un peu triste c'est un peu cédé
la ville du 10 à 20 ans quand c'est
l'été les vacances d'été l'habitude
c'est blindé demande tu vois tout le
monde sourire rigoler là on dirait que
c'est un but fantôme quoi un marché
fantôme qui devra attendre avant de
retrouver ses couleurs et ses clients
prévu initialement pour une quinzaine de
jours
le confinement annoncé par emmanuel
macron pourrait bien être prolongée
comme chez nos voisins italiens
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur cette crise du
coronavirus avec un notamment à les
conséquences économiques et puis en
france 108 nouveaux décès le seuil des
10000 qu'a franchie
[Musique]
en fait c'est le révélateur c'est le
catalyseur d'une situation qui n'a
jamais été réglé depuis 2008 on a un
coronavirus qui révèle une crise de fond
une crise structurelle sur les marchés
financiers qu'il faut pas tout attribuer
au corps à des virus le coronavirus nous
met dans une situation exceptionnelle
parce que là réellement on n'avait
jamais vu ça
on s'aperçoit que des entreprises en
fait non pas les flux de trésorerie et
non pas les profits qu'ils étaient
alignés avec leurs niveaux de dette
de toute façon elles vont elles vont
couler je vais emprunter si j'ai des
marchés je vais emprunter si j'ai des
clients je vais emprunter si je dois
faire un investissement mais je n'ai pas
emprunté parce que les taux sont passés
de 3 1
il va falloir soutenir la demande parce
que c'est une crise de demandes et on va
inciter les gens à s'endetter mais le
coeur du problème c'est la dette
il est évident que vous allez avoir une
action concertée des banques centrales
qui vont vous dire no limit
s'il faut cinq mille milliards on mettra
cinq mille milliards s'il en faut dix
mille ans dans la tradition
[Musique]
le général guisan en fait été
effectivement est un condisciple d'un
peu de polluants abriel donc il est il
est l école de brienne en même temps en
même temps que napoléon s'est il est
mort donc là une des dernières personnes
à l'avoir vue c'est napoléon donc c'est
très important
ensuite c'est un général qui a fait
toute sa carrière militaire qui est mort
au combat qui est mort en russie
c'est l'un des camarades les plus
proches de napoléon son nom est gravé
deux fois sur l'arc de triomphe à paris
on savait évidemment qu'il avait été
enterré en russie seul son coeur avait
été rapatrié en france
au cimetière du père lachaise
[Musique]
on a trouvé des traces d'un enterrement
je ne sais pas lequel michel michaud
attention on touche à rien
on est peut-être à 80 à 90% de chances
que la sépulture du général gaudin soit
là
[Musique]
ils sont élevés dans un seul but
ils ont un super pouvoir il commence à
s'entraîner dès le plus jeune âge
huit mois de formation intense
ce sont des rats et il sauve des vies
humaines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 merci nous rejoindrons direct sur
rt france un en espagne le nombre de cas
détectés dépasse désormais les 17000
selon un dernier bilan du centre d'
alerte sanitaire nationale
la pandémie a fait 7 167 morts dans le
pays soit près de 30% de plus en 24
heures ces chiffres font du royaume le
quatrième pays le plus touché dans le
monde alors que l'espagne vit à l'heure
du confinement généraliser le roi felipe
s'est adressé aux espagnols ont leur
souhaitons beaucoup de courage en
prestations sociales et bien dormi
carignan face à cette situation
la première chose que je veux dire c'est
que la reine nos fille et moi-même
adressons notre sincère affection à
toutes les familles qui ont
malheureusement subi la perte d'un de
leurs proches
ils voulaient renvoyons également à ceux
qui sont particulièrement affectés ou à
leur entourage par ce virus et ses
conséquences à vous tous nous vous
souhaitons beaucoup de force et de
courage
maintenant nous devons résister accepter
la situation nous devons changer notre
mode de vie et notre comportement en
suivant les indications de nos autorités
et les recommandations de nos experts
pour être en mesure de vaincre le virus
chacun doit contribuer en adaptant ses
attitudes et ses actions
je sais que c'est facile à dire et je
sais que ce n'est pas du tout facile à
faire dans ce listing là le pays est en
état d'urgence et au confinement depuis
dimanche les habitants n'ont plus le
droit de sortir de chez eux sauf pour
faire des courses aller à la pharmacie
ou travailler si c'est vraiment
nécessaire
les écoles universités bars restaurants
et commerces non alimentaires sont
fermés les autorités ont déjà annoncé
que le confinement pourrait se prolonger
elles ont aussi déployé l'armée les
militaires sont désormais dans les rues
pour désinfecter et sécuriser les lieux
sensibles de son côté l'industrie
pharmaceutique fonctionne à plein régime
pour assurer la production et la
distribution de médicaments
certains hôpitaux sont débordés on a
d'ailleurs appris aujourd'hui qu'une
infirmière de 52 ans est décédé en
raison du corona virus au pays basque
il s'agit de la première dans le secteur
de la santé mais tout de même chaque
soir à 20 heures les habitants sortent à
leur fenêtre pour applaudir et remercier
le personnel soignant mais un nombre de
cas qui explose en espagne ces dernières
24 heures pour en parler nous sommes
savait qu'à arroser horace alonso
juriste franco-espagnole bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vos terrasses alonso
l'espagne qui est désormais le pays le
plus touché de l'europe après l'italie
comment vous l'expliquez c'est difficile
à expliquer je crois que même les les
spécialistes les épidémiologistes et les
médecins ont du mal à expliquer la
vitesse à laquelle les pays les uns
derrière les autres ont été contaminés
ce qui y sont lumière c'est que les
chiffres évoluent très vite vous aviez
parlé tout à l'heure d'un nombre d'un
nombre de décès un peu inférieur à 800
on est et on a déjà dépassé
malheureusement les 803 décès c'est des
chiffres que j'ai relevé à 18 heures il
ya dix sept mille 300 malades dans toute
l'espagne est avec une grande
concentration de malades dont les
régions de madrid de catalogne
et du pays basque alors la vitesse à
laquelle se propage le virus
je crois que cette question elle se pose
un peu à tous les pays dans des pays
comme comme les pays latins la france
l'espagne et l'italie
c'est vrai que je pense que le il faut
expliquer aussi que les gens sortent
beaucoup les gens j'allais dire son sont
toujours en contact les uns avec les
autres games une
une forme de vie qui plus chaleureuses
peut être que dans les pays du nord de
l'europe peut-être ça peut expliquer
aussi la rapidité de la contamination
mais surtout on est face à quelque chose
qu'on n'a jamais vus auparavant
on n'a jamais été confrontée à une crise
sanitaire de cette ampleur avec une
maladie donc ce coronavirus pour lequel
pour l'instant il n'y a toujours pas de
vaccin
toujours pas de traitement directement
efficace et ça pose énormément de
problèmes
l'espagne prend comme la france et
l'italie les mêmes mesures aujourd'hui
le gouvernement à déclarer l'état
d'alarmé en espagne sur tout le
territoire espagnol avec maintenant une
gestion beaucoup plus centralisée des
choses c'est à dire une prise en main
des choses par le gouvernement central
ce qui est une nouveauté dans un pays
aussi décentraliser que l'espagne ce qui
n'est pas parfois sans friction
notamment avec le problème éternel des
ddd certains partir des pans dentiste
catalans qui cherchent encore à voir
derrière cette centralisation dictée par
la nécessité
une sorte de manoeuvre politique qui
n'existe pas il ya largement une
consensus une quasi unanimité des forces
politiques pour soutenir le gouvernement
en espagne comme dans les autres pays et
je crois que c'est une bonne chose pour
l'instant il faut renforcer cette unité
le combat se mène avec tout le monde
avec tous les citoyens les citoyens en
restant chez eux le personnel sanitaire
on l'a vu
il tombe tous les personnels qui sont
nécessaires pour faire fonctionner le
pays dans ses fonctions basiques la
distribution des aliments l'alimentation
qui est nécessaire pour tous les
habitants espagnols comme ça l'est aussi
en france et aussi le bon
approvisionnement en médicaments et en
matériel sanitaire des pharmacies et
surtout des hôpitaux bien sûr vous
parliez de cette prise en charge du
gouvernement central 1 de cette crise
est ce que les mesures ont été prises
peut-être un peu tard en espagne
également à l'instar certainement de de
tous les pays d'europe
si je pense que c'est toujours facile de
juger des actions d'un gouvernement
comme ça après coup
quand on est dans le feu de l'action et
sur le moment c'est très compliqué comme
on dira si tel ou tel pays a pris des
mesures en avance ou en retard c'est moi
je dis que je dirais que c'est
extrêmement difficile à analyser
pourquoi parce que c'est ce virus est
parti d'un pays comme la chine dont on
ne peut pas dire que l'information et
transparentes
on a vu également qu' il ya eu par
exemple un pays qui a été relativement
épargné par les contagions c est un pays
comme la russie où parfois on peut aussi
douter de la sincérité de l'information
des médias officiels donc c'est très
difficile d'analyser dans ces conditions
là si tel ou tel gouvernement a pris à
temps où on n'a pas pris à temps les
mesures nécessaires
c'est un dilemme je crois que pour tous
les gouvernements en europe comme
ailleurs il fallait faire un choix entre
paralyser l'économie comme on le fait
aujourd'hui avec cette obligation de
confinement en france en espagne en
italie et bientôt dans d'autres pays il
faut paralyser l'économie pour accorder
au secteur sanitaire aux médecins aux
hôpitaux le temps de s'organiser face à
l'avalanche des nouveaux malades
donc c'est extrêmement difficile à quel
moment on prend une décision de
confinement qui va provoquer des
concessionnaires et des conséquences
économiques bien sûr très importante
dans tous les pays européens et à quel
moment les prendre quel moment on doit
les prendre c'est très difficile de
j'ai l'opportunité et la sagesse d'un
gouvernement dans une situation que
personne n'avait prévu qui est tout à
fait de nouvelles et inédites et qui a
pris des dimensions mondiales en
quelques semaines ce qui ne s'était
quasiment jamais vu dans l'histoire
jusqu'à maintenant c'est aussi là d un
des effets de ce qu'on appelle la
globalisation la mondialisation les gens
voyagent beaucoup plus qu'avant les
citoyens d'un pays vont beaucoup plus
facilement l'autre bout de la planète
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus facilement
qu'il ya 10 ou 20 ans donc tout ça ce
sont des facteurs de risques naturels de
contamination qu'on avait peut-être pas
il ya 30 ou 40 ans l'impact de cette
maladie il beau couple est d'autant plus
grand aujourd'hui que les moyens de
communication les transports aériens les
transports terrestres aussi sont
beaucoup plus rapides aujourd'hui qu'il
y a vingt ou trente ans je pense que
c'est ça qui explique aussi la rapidité
de la contagion et surtout roux est
surtout là je pense que le plus
important ce que pose comme question
cette crise sanitaire c'est de savoir si
nous avons tout fait dans les pays
européens pour soutenir le secteur de la
santé les médecins les hôpitaux il ya
beaucoup de mouvements sociaux dans les
hôpitaux français depuis deux 2 2 3 ans
il y en a eu aussi en espagne on a dans
certaines régions voulu absolument
privatiser une grande partie du secteur
de santé
peut-être qu'ils se posent et de la
question savoir quel choix on doit faire
dans un pays moderne sur le secteur de
la santé pour être capable de faire face
à des crises comme ça on voit que dans
tous les pays manque des masques de
protection il manque du matériel de base
y compris pour les médecins c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'aurait jamais
imaginé il ya seulement quelques
semaines
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
or as alonso d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rtl et les italiens eux aussi
resteront chez eux plus longtemps encore
que prévu alors que le pays a enregistré
hier son plus lourd bilan humain depuis
le début de l'épidémie avec 4 175
nouveaux décès en 24 heures le président
du conseil a prévenu que les mesures de
confinement serait prolongée et elle y
compte depuis aujourd'hui davantage de
morts qu'en chine les explications de
guillaume un rossi
alors que les habitants de la péninsule
sont confinés depuis le 10 mars dernier
le nombre de contaminés et de décès
enregistrés quotidiennement augmente
chaque jour près d'un demi-millier de
morts pour la seule journée de mercredi
plus du double du même jour la semaine
précédente à bergame en lombardie
la première des régions européennes
touchées par le virus les hôpitaux et
les morgues sont surchargées dans ses
camions militaires
une soixantaine de cercueils en route
pour les crématoriums des municipalités
voisines bergame où le chef du
département de médecine de l'hôpital
pape jean xxiii a lancé un appel à
l'aide ce jeudi nous sommes en pleine
urgence avec cette pandémie de
coronavirus notre personnel de santé
infirmières et médecins travaillent 24
heures sur 24 sans compter leurs heures
pour lutter contre cette situation
incroyable oui 12 non nous ne savons pas
combien de temps cette pandémie va durer
nous avons désespérément besoin
d'infirmières et de médecins ainsi que
deux ventilateurs et de dispositifs de
protection et l'italie est loin d'en
avoir terminé avec l'épidémie
initialement prévue jusqu'au 3 avril
le chef du gouvernement giuseppe konté a
annoncé un prolongement du confinement
de l'ensemble du pays
les mesures que nous avons prises tant
celles qui ont entraîné la fermeture
d'une grande partie des entreprises et
des activités individuelles dans le pays
que celle concernant l'école ne peuvent
être que prolonger à leurs échéances
les italiens devront demeurer confiné
plus longtemps et dans des conditions
que certains responsables politiques
veulent plus sévère le président
d'emilie romagne a par exemple signé ce
mercredi une ordonnance limitant les
déplacements au seul réseau médical de
travail ou pour aller faire ses courses
excluant de fait la promenade ou les
activités sportives en plein air des
recommandations similaires ont été
formulées par le gouverneur de la
vénétie voisine qui propose même d'aller
plus loin qu'une simple interdiction de
sortie contrôler les personnes leurs
mouvements grâce au téléphone portable
pour vérifier le respect des raids
contre les coronavirus serait une
excellente solution mais des règles
légales sont nécessaires car il s'agit
de fait d'une limitation de la vie
privée et comme ailleurs sur la planète
les italiens guette le pays
de propagation de l'épidémie un pic dont
la date est encore incertaine
l'université de gênes avance une date
comprise entre le 23 et le 25 mars le
conseil national de la recherche quant à
lui prévoit une stabilisation du nombre
de personnes infectées
entre le 25 mars et le 15 avril mais
tous reconnaissent l'incertitude liée à
de telles prédictions
le pire est passé dans les premiers
foyers d'infection comme un co deniau
par exemple où plus aucun cas n'a été
enregistré depuis le 14 mars mais une
augmentation du nombre de contaminés est
toujours en cours dans la région du sud
où son parti de nombreux italiens du
nord que l'épidémie atteigne son pic
dans une semaine ou dans un mois
l'italie doit s'attendre à au moins
plusieurs centaines de morts d'ici là et
davantage encore une fois l'épidémie
terminé l italie qui dépasse la chine
pour le nombre de morts pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec domenico
quirico journaliste est la stampa
bonsoir dominicaux quirico ce triste
constat effectivement plus de morts en
italie qu'en chine comment réagit-on en
italie à ce diagnostic
la situation est terrible surtout aux
dingues dans la région du nord la
lombardie veneto et les milliers romagne
qui il sent les gens plus moderne et
plus organisée du pays mais sont les
plus touchées de la pandémie
le grand problème c'est le sud où là la
santé publique est très mal passée et
donc on peut c'est si la pandémie va a
touché le sud du pays
c'est vraiment un grand problème tout le
tout le gouvernement a pris des
décisions très dures a fermé à fermer
tous les écoles
les cafés le spark sera beaucoup deux
entreprises sont fermées mais le nombre
de contaminés va arrêter et c'est pas on
ne peut pas prévoir à quelle date
tout est terminé il ya une inversion de
la courbe est ce que c'est un espoir en
italien on estime qu'on est dans le pic
et que les choses vont aller mieux on
reste très prudent il faut être très
très prudent on disait qu'ils dans cette
semaine c'était possible qui va caler le
nombre des quotas mini mais c'est pas
vrai les membres sans intérêt de motets
et le problème en italie ce qui la
population est trop vieux lilian par
chantage de population très vieux donc
plus touchés par la par la pandémie et
sauve a expliqué le nombre de morts qui
est vraiment un terrible vraiment
terrible il ya une prolongation des
mesures de confinement on pouvait s'y
attendre comment ont réagi les italiens
c'est quelque chose qui qu'ils vivent
difficilement comme vous le rappelez
notre invité espagnol tout à l'heure
c'est vrai que ce sont des cultures on
aime se retrouver dans la rue c'est une
culture très très convivial où les gens
ne sont pas chacun de leur côté comment
le vivent t-il le pôle est qu'il y
encore beaucoup de monde dans les rues
il ya beaucoup de monde qui va faire du
sport qui va faire de jogging qui va
dans les parcs publics pour pour le
match de football etc et surtout les
jeunes au début on pensait que c'était
une chose hongrie pas plus et s était
une erreur et aujourd'hui
les rues sont encore avec beaucoup de
voitures
il y a la permission qui on va assigner
mondaine soi même mais c'est pas bon ça
parce que surtout en emilie romagne en
au baby les gouverneurs bon à fermer
vraiment haut et c'est peut-être que
bien la décision à venir à la fin mais
domenico quirico justement je vous
entends et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
inquiétant lors on ne lit pas forcément
qu'on fait mieux en france a la preuve
aujourd'hui on a fait fermer les plages
mais est ce que ce n'est pas là le
problème justement peut-être que les
italiens ne respecte pas assez
strictement les mesures on rappelle
qu'en chine il n'est plus de passer
enfin plus patient pardon plus de cas
nouveaux apparemment d'après ce qu'on
nous dit mais il ya eu d un confinement
très stricte des mesures draconiennes
alors le problème qui sait la sinne
c'est une dictature c'est pas possible
donc c'est plus facile eric il faut il
faut avant de fermer les libertés
individuelles
il faut être très très prudent très
prudent
pour quelles raisons vous pensez que ce
n'est pas souhaitable aujourd'hui dans
des démocraties sa pose et peut-être
effectivement agrobio de vidéographie ou
empêcher à tout le monde de sortir de la
maison il faut faire des lois c'est pas
une chose compacité avec indifférence
il faut méditer beaucoup je pense vous
pensez que les italiens ne sont pas
prêts à ça quand il s'agit peut-être
d'une question de vie ou de mort
beaucoup de leurs concitoyens je pense
que nous disent open merci beaucoup en
tout cas dominicaux quirico d'avoir été
avec nos journalistes à l'instant pas
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france nous
avoir parlé donc de la situation en
italie
le mexique lui est peu touchée pour
l'instant en tout cas par l'épidémie de
coronavirus avec un seul décès
et 118 cas de contamination pour
l'instant mais il garde en mémoire
l'épidémie de grippe porcine c'était en
2019 qui avait tué 1300 personnes
certaines régions apprennent donc des
mesures exceptionnelles à hidalgo un
hôpital gonflable sera bientôt
opérationnel robin paris avec mathilde
romagnan une structure gonflable de 1800
mètres carrés
voilà à quoi ressemble cet hôpital
éphémère installé sur la plaza
bicentenario dans la ville de pachuca
dans l'état d'hidalgo aucun cas de
coronavirus n'a été recensé dans cette
région située au nord de mexico
ce qui n'empêche pas les autorités
locales d'employer les grands moyens
nous n'avons toujours pas de décès et du
gouverneur nous a donné comme
instruction de le monter au plus vite
pour pouvoir prévenir on doit être à peu
près 100 travailleurs sur le site
la structure comporte neuf modules de
consultation externe avec une capacité
de 80 patients par jour ainsi que 40
lits 10 pour les soins intensifs
cet hôpital avait été acquis en 2014
pour faire face à une recrudescence de
choléra dans la région
la population est partagée devant cette
initiative entre enthousiasme et
inquiétude
ces petites maisons de l'hôpital ça me
paraît bien une bonne idée pour que tout
se passe bien d'une manière positive
c'est bien et c'est mal bien pour les
malades et mal pour nous qui vivons ici
c'est une prévention pour les personnes
qui sont malades ou qui vont tomber
malade mais c'est un danger pour nous
aussi
c'est une bonne prévention mais un
mauvais emplacement surtout parce qu'un
hôpital devrait être situé dans un
endroit où il ya plus d'air libre où il
n'y a pas autant de personnes c'est une
zone scolaire il y à des écoles primaire
et des maternelles
il ya aussi beaucoup de gens qui passent
quotidiennement pour travailler le
gouvernement fédéral à lure à 3,5
milliards de pesos soit environ 133 1000
euros pour acheter tout ce qu'il faut du
matériel médical aux fournitures de
laboratoire les états travaillent en
étroite collaboration avec l'état
fédéral pour contenir la pandémie de
grippe le fait d'aller los gaujos local
gouvernance estatal center de païs et
entre le gouvernement fédéral et les
gouvernements locaux et les états il y à
une série de mesures importantes qui ont
été prises
face à ce qui se passe dans le monde
avec le coronavirus chaque état fait son
propre effort pour prendre les mesures
préventives et surtout nécessaire pour
qu'à la fin nous puissions contrôler
cette situation plus que la maladie le
gouvernement fédéral mexicain craint
surtout pour l'instant un effondrement
de son économie soucieux de ne pas
freiner le commerce et des échanges
il n'a pas encore décidé de fermer les
frontières du pays le mexique qui se
prépare pour en parler nous sommes avec
catania ouverte à mexicaine vivant à
paris bonsoir tania au hertha
vous êtes confinés comme tout le monde à
paris que vous inspirent ces chiffres
encore plutôt clément on va dire ça
comme ça pour pour le mexique ça
s'explique alors ce qu'il faut savoir
bonsoir d'abord ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que les mexique à une quinzaine de
jours de retard on va dire par rapport à
l'espagne vous en avait parlé tout à
l'heure et pour l'instant on a recensé
plus d'une centaine des cas de malades
118 cas où aujourd'hui je crois et il y
a eu un mort de récents c'est une
personne diabétique donc évidemment les
populations fragiles les diabètes au
mexique était une préoccupation
voilà les il ya une sorte d'attentisme
et les présidences se veut on va dire
rassurant il prépare les choses mais la
population effectivement commencent à
s'inquiéter alors ils préparent les
choses effectivement il ya l'exemple
finnois européen
donc retour sur expérience certainement
et puis l'épidémie de grippe porcine en
2009 elle a laissé des traces au mexique
certainement oui absolument tout le
monde a en tête l'épisode de 2009 où il
y a eu vraiment de la même manière à peu
près à la même époque
ben tout de suite des mesures prises par
les présidents de l'époque felipe
calderon qui a décidé effectivement dès
prolonger les vacances et de prendre des
mesures de fermeture comme actuellement
en france aux tous débuts fermeture des
bars discothèques restaurants et la vie
s'est arrêtée
effectivement à mexico s'était vraiment
palpable avec les embouteillages qui lit
habituellement c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment très très présent dans la
tête de tous les mexicains et c'est pour
cela que quelque part le
la préoccupation des mexicains des vans
un petit peu le ton rassurant du
président puisque les gens ont ça en
tête et ils commencent à s'inquiéter
avec déjà des achats on va dire de de
prévention si ce n'est de benfica et est
il notre préoccupation c'est
effectivement la fragilité du système de
santé mexicain la fragilité du système
de santé ça veut dire quoi concrètement
les hôpitaux qui n'ont pas de moyens
également des mexicains qui seront
peut-être à l'instar des états unis
obligé de payer eux mêmes leurs soins
avec un système de santé très moyen très
voilà peu efficace peu efficace oui
alors d'après ce que j'ai pu lire
d'après ce que j'ai fait c'est les
systèmes mexicains aujourd'hui
actuellement compte environ une 5000
lits dont la moitié des systèmes de
respiratoires je ne sais pas comment ça
s'appelle un techniquement il faut
reporter ça au nombre de la population
mexicaine qui et les doubles d'un de la
france donc pour à peu près les mêmes
nombres de 10 elle est même nombre de
systèmes de des respirations donc plus
les de la couverture sociale on va dire
qu'ils qui n'a pas de comparaison avec
ce qui peut se faire en europe en france
notamment
donc voilà ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
qu'il faut prendre en compte pour le
mexique c'est c'est une fragilité
j'en reviens à cette expérience
d'épidémie de grippe porcine en 2009
selon vous quelles seront justement les
premières mesures un petit peu fortes
prises par le gouvernement si l'épidémie
devaient s'accélérer au mexique ce
serait le confinement strict des tests
systématiques contrairement à la france
par exemple
alors pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu de
mesures de prises pour des tests à
grande échelle
les présidences c'est vraiment rassurant
on l'a taxé parfois même de prendre les
choses avec décontraction on va dire
avec sa conférence de presse matinale
qu'il tient tous les jours et dans
laquelle il a même évoqué ses grigris
pour se protéger c'est un petit peu de
la provocation de sa part évidemment
mais il annonce que des mesures qu'un
plan est en cours de préparation que
tout est prêt que le mexique est préparé
mais les mexicains sont vraiment
préoccupé et et peut-être que comme ça
c'est passé par d'un des épisodes dans
l'histoire du mexique notamment les
tremblements de terre de 1985 ou plus
récemment bel et bien c'est la société
civile qui va à peu prendre les devants
sur les mesures prises par les
politiques pour basse et j'ai essayé de
procès qui sont protégés la difficulté
au mexique c'est que comme vous le savez
il ya toute une partie d'économie
informelle avec beaucoup de personnes
qui vivent vraiment au jour le jour et
pour lesquels ça va être vraiment très
difficile et voilà merci en tout cas on
a bien compris merci
tania warta d'avoir été avec nous restez
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur cette crise du cornât
virus avec son volet économique jacques
sapiens nous expliquera dans son édito
par skype 1 aujourd'hui quelles
pourraient être les conséquences
économiques de cette crise sanitaire qui
devient une crise au économique
également
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici les sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les poussons thermique la stratégie
de conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillages deux fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
à ce type de pratiques il n'existe sur
la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez qui est sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les moyens
[Musique]
je suis venu ici pour essayer de plonger
à la limite de mes capacités
je n'aime pas le froid c'est un défi en
quelque sorte
essayez de plonger dans l'eau glacée
oh la vache
ce type qui a battu le record du monde
il a fait une autre plongée à 75 m je
dois plongé à 76 3 2 un départ
natation assez les chiens nordiques que
j'irai donc le chien de race husky de
sibérie et qu'est ce qu'ils représentent
pour vous ces chiens un meilleur
présente plein de choses parce qu une
motoneige c'est pas une machine
c'est pour vous faire plaisir bien
souvent qui courent chaque chine a son
caractère
il ya certaines de mes chiennes avec
lequel ryan par le regard on arrivait on
arrive à se comprendre
arrivé à un moment depuis des années on
prend à gauche
cette année elle nous a fait prendre la
piste par la droite au fait comment
alors
la chienne de tête à s'est retourné et
m'a dit tu es sur ton coup parce que
c'est pas par là qu'il faut aller c'est
d'autre côté
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur arte france pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi un confinement historique en
france qui pourrait être rallongée on
dénombre aujourd'hui dans le pays dit
1995 quatre confirmé coronavirus 372
décès 1122 cas graves sur les quatre
mille sept cent soixante et une
personnes hospitalisées le parlement
doit voter
l'état d'urgence sanitaire alors que la
crise du grenat virus menace de
paralyser l'économie mondiale les
gouvernements et banques centrales des
gaines des plans d'urgence massif pour
limiter les dégâts mais pas toujours
suffisant aux yeux les marchés
financiers alors comment ton qu'il de
réagir face à une crise qui pourrait
être plus grave que celle de 2008 avec
quels moyens et pour quelle efficacité
c'est la question à laquelle tentera de
répondre dans quelques instants
notre économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
les derniers bilans on dénombre en
france ce jeudi 10 1995 cas confirmés de
coronavirus 108 personnes de plus en 24
heures ont succombé à la maladie le
personnel hospitalier est tabou mais
tente de faire face en dépit d'un manque
de moyens
une pénurie de masques sur tous les
services sont saturés et la france se
prépare donc à la priorisation des soins
nous avons une épidémie qui s'étend et
une épidémie qui continue à s'aggraver
avec une circulation virale rapide et
intense dans de nombreuses zones du
territoire national nous allons donc
devoir affronter une épidémie importante
dans ces prochains jours avec évidemment
des incertitudes sur le comportement du
virus lui même et surtout nous devons
tout faire pour que les mesures
barrières individuelles et collectives
soient les plus efficaces possibles donc
réduire massivement tous nos contacts
aujourd'hui nous avons dit 1995 cas
confirmés par test pcr
parmi ces personnes quatre mille quatre
cent soixante et une personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisées
ce qui veut dire que 5000 personnes sont
à domicile confiné parmi les personnes
hospitalisées
on recense 1122 cas graves en
réanimation mais aussi près de 1300
retour à domicile de personnes guéries
le nombre de cas double tous les quatre
jours toutes les régions métropolitaines
et les territoires ultramarins sont
concernés les six régions les plus
touchées sont toujours les mêmes
la corse le grand est l'île de france la
bourgogne franche comté les hauts de
france et l'auvergne rhône-alpes
on observe des formes graves
essentiellement chez des adultes avec
une médiane à 60 en réanimation dont 50%
des cas ont moins de 60 ans et
malheureusement on déplore 372 décès
dont 6 % chez des moins de 60 ans mais
hier le gouvernement autorisé
l'instauration d'un état d'urgence
sanitaire accompagné de mesures
d'urgence pour soutenir l'économie
un texte débattu aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale en comité
restreint les précisions sur place de
notre reporter lit la fin
amouzou plusieurs mesures d'urgence
évoqué ce matin lors d'une séance de
questions au gouvernement dans une
ambiance assez étrange année dans un
hémicycle presque vide alors une petite
anecdote qui illustre l'ambiance étrange
qu'il y avait ce matin au palais bourbon
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie agnès pannier irina qui a
été prise d'une quinte de toux une
quinte de toux qui a été accueilli par
des sourires crispés dans un silence
assez inquiétant ça vous montre à quel
point cette séance ce matin était assez
particulière et puis comme on pouvait
s'y attendre toutes les questions
portait évidemment sur la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire sans précédent
avec notamment la question des masques
qui est revenu plusieurs fois le premier
ministre a été interpellé à plusieurs
reprises par tous les groupes présents
ici à l'assemblée nationale aussi bien
les socialistes que les républicains
olivier ferrand a tenté de déminer la
polémique sur le manque de matériel en
pointant du doigt une décision des
gouvernements précédents et puis un peu
plus tard matt hill panneau du groupe
elle est fille a demandé la création
d'un comité parlementaire de suivi
permanent pour dit-elle le plus de
transparence dans l'action du
gouvernement dans la gestion de cette
crise alors ensuite cette séance de
questions au gouvernement a duré qui a
duré à peu près une heure et demie a été
suivie dans l'après midi par une séance
cette fois ci pour examiner le projet de
loi de finances rectificative pardon le
gouvernement a annoncé qu'ils allaient
intégrer un plan de soutien de 45,1
milliards d'euros une première mesure
qui sera le report des charges fiscales
et sociales pour toutes les entreprises
sur le mois de mars c'est la déclaration
de bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie il a également évoqué la
création d'un fonds de solidarité visant
à soutenir les plus petites entreprises
les indépendants et les
micro-entreprises alors le député
charles de courson du groupe liberté et
territoires a estimé que l'hypothèse
d'un confinement d'un mois était un peu
trop optimiste nicolas dupont aignan de
la france de 2002 de boula france pardon
a dénoncé quant à lui le manque
d'anticipation du gouvernement dans
cette crise alors les débats se
poursuivent et les députés ont
semble-t-il vous
voulu montrer en tout cas aujourd'hui
qu'il prenait à coeur cette crise qui
frappe la france aujourd'hui alors que
le virus se propage à grande vitesse à
la gestion politique de la crise
sanitaire pour en parler nous sommes
avec denis demonpion éditorialiste
politique bonsoir denier à de
montpouillan merci d'être avec nous et
manuel macron qui a donc lancé cet état
d'urgence sanitaire était il nécessaire
selon vous à quoi doit-on s'attendre
précisément oui il est absolument
indispensable parce que il suffit de
baser sur ce qui s'est passé en chine et
d'ailleurs ce ne sont pas seulement les
politiques en france mais également je
voyais aujourd'hui les professeurs
chinois qui très grand penseur chinois
qui exerce à shanghai qui disait que si
pas seulement la france mais toute
l'europe ne prend pas des mesures
drastiques de confinement qui sont à mon
sens d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui très
insuffisante compte tenu des j'allais
dire des infractions qui sont commises
confinement décrété et bien cette
professeur chinois qui ont de
l'expérience du virus considère que
l'europe et peut-être même les états
unis c'est de ce qu'ils ont l'air d'en
prendre le chemin est bien géré on le
nombre de cas x 10 tous les 19 jours
s'il n'y a pas de mesures plus
contraignantes que celles qui sont
prises aujourd'hui donc état d'urgence
sanitaire
on peut quand même pas a critiqué une
mesure de bon sens d'ailleurs tous les
deux médecins soignants professeurs
interrogés aujourd'hui en france sont
d'accord pour que cette mesure soit
prise est respectée avec la plus grande
rigueur
denis demonpion à votre avis on doit
s'attendre à des mesures justement
peut-être encore plus strictes 1 vous
parliez justement de ce médecin
le docteur klein qui effectivement
disait si on n'arrive pas à faire autant
de mesures drastiques en chine
on doit s'attendre au pire on entendait
également un autre journaliste italien
nous dire que ce genre de mesures ne
sont pas vraiment possible en europe
dans des pays aux latins qui ne sont pas
habitués à beaucoup d'autorité quel est
votre avis oui absolument
c'est toute la question en france c'est
à dire que aussi longtemps qu'il n'y a
pas de mesures coercitives parce que
vous savez il ya toujours en france le
pays des droits de l'homme de la liberté
etc
mais on est dans un cas de figure tout à
fait exceptionnelle enfin tous les
médecins et les professeurs de santé le
dise donc c'est un sujet à traiter avec
effectivement beaucoup de sérieux
j'avais en chine s'était passé la chose
suivante il avait commencé au moment du
confinement par autoriser les gens à
faire leurs courses de spa il avait
laissé les magasins ouverts et puis
ensuite très rapidement ils ont pris une
autre mesure c'est que les gens ne
pouvaient évidemment il leur fallait un
papier une autorisation aller faire les
courses que tous les trois jours
et enfin pour finir pour arriver à
juguler ce qu on a vieilli et sa
propagation
ils ont fini par comment dirais-je
organiser des groupes de gens qui
distribuait des des paniers au bas des
immeubles et que les gens allaient
chercher il descendait de leur
appartement pour aller les chercher
peut-être faudra-t-il en arriver là en
france parce que vous disiez aussi que
le le commentaire lu confinement a été
elle était annoncée pour 15 jours mais
on voit déjà dans les conversations est
d'ailleurs le premier ministre hier le
disaient que ça ne ferait être suffisant
donc on voit bien qu'ils sont en train
de préparer l'opinion publique à
accepter une période de confinement très
longue et dans les milieux médicaux très
informés et bien évidemment ils sont
premiers rangs de la bataille contre les
virus et bien ils disent qu'ils font
il faudrait au moins 50 jours de
confinement au bas mot d'allemand
effectivement pas très optimiste mais
c'est ce qu'on entend de la bouche des
scientifiques
tous les jours vous avez raison emmanuel
macron qui dit qu'ils pensent tirer qui
s'est engagé pardon à tirer toutes les
conséquences de cette crise comment
interpréter cette promesse on voit déjà
qu'il ya de gros un fléchissement dans
la politique d' emmanuel macron on
savait c'est pas un fléchissement dans
sa politique c'est que étant donné
l'urgence il n'a eu d'autre choix que de
mettre sous le boisseau tous les projets
de loi qui lave est dans son tiroir et
même de suspendre la réforme des
retraites dont je rappellerai pas la
bagarre qu'est la cité et les la vague
de manifestations
donc en réalité emmanuel macron sadac
saga swiss et il essaie de s'adapter
comme il l'avait fait déjà avec avec les
gilet jaune
mais rien ne dit encore qu'il a pris la
mesure des changements s'imposeront
après car sans doute en faudra-t-il car
comment peut-on expliquer que tous les
médicaments soient fabriqués en dehors
de france n'est ce pas qu'il faille
attendre la chine etc pour pour espérer
des médicaments alors que la france a
toujours été en pointe jusqu'à la
période des localisations globalisation
mondialisation alors je sais que ce sont
des des commandes est dédé
une fois forte et forcément partagé je
lisais aujourd'hui des déclarations de
pascal lamy d'anciens responsables
européens au sein de l'om c'est qu'ils
avaient beaucoup plus vrai lui pour
justement cette mondialisation et bien
même encore maintenant devant la
tragédie que nous vivons il a encore du
mal à faire une espèce de l'examen de
conscience et et revenir sur ces
idéologies qui ont quand même fait si on
en juge aujourd'hui par ce qui se passe
beaucoup de dégâts merci denis demonpion
éditorialistes politiques d'avoir été
avec nous plan massif de la bce pour
sauver la zone euro chèque aux ménages
américains pour soutenir la consommation
est depuis quelques jours les banques
centrales et les gouvernements se
mobilisent pour contenir les effets
dévastateurs de la crise du coronavirus
qui n'écarte pas pour autant les risques
de récession et peine à calmer les
marchés financiers
ces mesures sans précédent seront elles
suffisantes pour éviter un effondrement
quel monde économique se dessine au delà
de cette épidémie envoie ça tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
dans son édito une fois n'est pas
coutume par skype un confinement oblige
cher jacques on va s'y habituer avec
toutes nos excuses évidemment de ne pas
vous recevoir
sur ce plateau alors jacques que la
crise menace 1 2
paralysée comment vous voyez les choses
eh bien vous savez stéphanie faut
d'abord dire que la situation est
complètement inédite
outre la crise des marchés financiers
dont on a déjà parlé ici c'est le
passage ou confinement des divers pays
qui met les économies en sommeil le
risque évidemment et qu'elle ne se
réveille pas une fois l'épidémie passé
c'est un peu ce que j'appelle moi le
syndrome où les fées blanche-neige tout
le monde connaît le compte
le virus est bien ça serait l'équivalent
de la pomme qui plonge blanche neige
dans le sommeil et les sept nains les
banquiers centraux qui ne peuvent pas
faire grand chose voire même qu'ils ne
peuvent rien faire alors on le sait dans
la vie réelle il n'y a pas de prince
charmant mais il y avait tant à l'icf
aux dons permettre aux salariés et aux
entreprises de traverser cette période
dans les moins mauvaises conditions
seulement on peut se demander si les
mesures qui sont qui seront prises
évidemment nous ne dessine pas en
réalité une économie très différente de
ce que nous connaissions avant cette
épidémie alors jacques comment évaluez
vous les réponses données jusqu'ici à
cette crise sous il faut commencer tout
d'abord par voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe et où vous êtes vous savez une des
choses c'est la trajectoire que me
suivant alors une chose qui est très
intéressant c'est de regarder les cartes
de la contamination et on voit que
presque systématiquement ce sont les
régions les plus développées qui sont
touchés comme en italie par exemple on
va le voir cette contamination elle est
très grave ou les très graves dans le
nord qui est la région la plus
industrielle du pays
d'ailleurs c'était un petit peu la même
chose parce que en chine
l'épidémie a commencé à one et one c'est
le berceau de l'industrie automobile
chinoise avec toutes ses usines
alors jacques pourquoi ces mesures de
confinement sont elles en train de
plonger l'économie dans une forme de
léthargie
et bien si vous voulez c'est fanny là
encore il faut bien regarder comment ça
se passe et comment sont les cartes
si vous regardez la carte de l'italie
mais aussi si vous regardez la carte de
la contamination en allemagne
c'est une carte qui est un petit peu
plus anciennes je n'ai pas trouvé de
cartes plus récente malheureusement eh
bien ce sont les régions qui sont le qui
ont le plus de relation directe ou
indirecte avec la chine qui sont touchés
les premières en allemagne qui est un
gros partenaire industriel de la chine
la carte de la contamination correspond
en réalité aux régions les plus
mondialisées
en fait c'est le va et vient des
ingénieurs des quatre commerciaux des
techniciens break qui a apporté le virus
et à partir de là ces régions ont
progressivement contaminé le reste du
pays en france d'ailleurs il faut le
rappeler
la première région touchée l'oise là
aussi été du fait de gens rentrant de
chine
alors jacques comment cela
s'explique-t-il et bien comme je le dis
c'est évidemment le problème général du
commerce de la mondialisation
mais ce qui me semble aussi le plus
intéressant c'est de regarder les
risques de récession et quelle ampleur
elle pourrait avoir et bien prenons le
cas de l'exemple chinois la consommation
d'énergie a chuté là bas à moins de 40 %
de son niveau normal comme les gens
confiné doivent continuer de se chauffer
de s'éclairer on peut penser que en
réalité c'est pratiquement 80% de
l'industrie et des différentes activités
économiques qui ont été à l'arrêt si on
transpose ce que l'on a connu en chine
en france ou en italie
ça voudrait dire que momentanément la
production de richesse va baisser dans
notre pays ou en italie de 20 à 30 % sur
le premier et le deuxième semestre alors
là encore quels sont les secteurs qui
vont être les plus touchés bien on les
voit à l'écran l'industrie midam ans va
être touché tant par les effets du
confit nom qui arrête les usines que par
le manque des pièces détachées dans les
usines qui fonctionne encore pour le
bâtiment et travaux publics
on voit que ce sont les principaux
chantiers qui sont aujourd'hui arrêter
ou fortement ralenti on sait que madame
pénicaud s'en est inquiété mais on voit
bien que les différents entreprises de
construction peuvent faire difficilement
autre shoot que de s'arrêter
et puis c'est évidemment pour les
services et le commerce
mis à part évidemment l'alimentaire et
les pharmacies que l'impact des mesures
de confinement est et sera le plus
dramatique
alors jacques concrètement quelles
peuvent être les conséquences pour les
entreprises comme pour les salariés
alors on va commencer par les
entreprises pour les entreprises d'abord
elles vont plus avoir deux rentrées
d'argent par contre leurs emprunts
courent toujours
donc il y a un problème immédiat de
liquidité au delà de ce problème
il va y avoir un problème de solvabilité
en effet les entreprises n'ont plus de
revenus mais elles doivent toujours
payer leurs employés les frais fixes et
herat si cela dure
la survie de très nombreuses entreprises
sera mise en question
vous savez en italie d'ores et déjà on
annonce une possibilité de faillite pour
12%
les pme italiennes après il ya le
problème pour les salariés le problème
se pose d'abord pour agir et les
salariés des entreprises
évidemment ça va poser la question du
chômage technique ou partiel et on sait
déjà que mardi dernier il y avait à peu
près deux millions de salariés qui
étaient concernés mais le problème le
plus important
il va se poser pour les travailleurs
indépendants les auto-entrepreneurs et
là ça risque d'être encore plus
dramatique
alors jacques le gouvernement a pris des
mesures lesquels et pourquoi faire alors
c'est vrai le gouvernement a pris
beaucoup de mesures et il a assez bien
réagi à l'opulence économique si on fait
la liste des mesures mais on va voir
quelle est relativement complet en
réalité on voit que ces mesures coup les
principaux risques ajoute aussi la
déclaration faite cette semaine par le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
qui a évoqué la possibilité d'une
nationalisation partielle ou totale
on pense par exemple à air france le
seul point faible pour l'instant
concerne évidemment la question du
revenu des travailleurs indépendants
mais ça va coûter évidemment très cher
jacques on imagine eh bien oui
ah oui vous avez tout à fait raison et
stéphanie le gouvernement parle de 45
milliards d'euros dette directe plus 300
milliards de garanties de crédit
en allemagne on annonce déjà plus de 500
milliards d'euros en garanties de crédit
en italie le parlement a déjà voté une
loi qui prévoit 25 milliards
des directs et ce n'est qu'un début
alors oui vous avez tout à fait raison
ça va coûter très cher le président de
la république avait annoncé des mesures
quoi qu'il en coûte vous rappeler cette
formule a été répétée trois fois dans
son intervention du 12 mars
et bien voila quoi qu'il en coûte nous y
sommes
le ministère des finances estime que le
déficit va monter à 3,9 pour cent du
pipe cette année mais vous savez quand
on sait qu'en 2009
et en réponse d'ailleurs à la crise des
subprimes à l'époque le déficit avait
été de plus de 7%
il est très probable en réalité que l'on
sera largement au-dessus de 4% du
déficit à la fin de l'année et la
question évidemment
qui va payer et oui bonne question c'est
fait on en revient toujours là et vous
avez tout à fait raison
alors la banque centrale européenne a
fait très fort avec un plan massif de
750 milliards d'euros de rachats de
titres de dette publique et privée
elle devrait donc certainement acquérir
directement des bons du trésor qu'ils
soient français italien allemand ou
espagnol
cependant on sait bien que sur ce
problème et c'est vrai que ça met en
cause directement la charte qui fixe
l'organisation de la banque centrale
européenne il y à des résistances
en particulier il faut bien le dire du
côté allemand et du côté néerlandais
cette question du financement va donc
être au coeur
des débats dans l'union européenne dès
la fin du printemps ou le début de set
est justement jacques vont m'apporter
tout trouvé ma transition l'union
européenne dans tout ça alors eh oui
stéphanie l'union européenne eh bien on
peut la qualifier deux grandes muettes
de grandes absentes
on constate que les pays de l'union
européenne gère cette crise
individuellement l'union européenne a
été incapable de réagir que ce soit au
niveau sanitaire mais aussi au niveau
économique
la ce a des conséquences des jeux en
italie l'opinion est en train de tourner
franchement hostile à l'union européenne
à l'union européenne
67 % des italiens pensent que
l'appartenance à l'ue est un problème
alors que seulement 21 % des italiens
estiment qu'elle est un avantage alors
eh bien oui alesi alesi jacques pardon
heures si les règles de l'euro ne sont
pas rapidement modifiées et si le statut
de l'union européenne ne subit pas des
transformations importantes
une nouvelle crise de l'euro surviendra
dès 2021 alors jacques ce que vous nous
raconter c'est on l'entend comme ça un
changement énorme qui se prépare oui
effectivement
en fait on go on le voit bien c'est
toute la construction européenne de
l'union européenne elle-même à l'euro
qui est aujourd'hui ébranlée par cette
crise et qui devra rapidement changer ou
périr
au delà cette crise
elle signe le retour du politique
rappelons encore les déclarations du 12
mars on du 16 mars emmanuel macron mais
c'est aussi le retour de l'état dans
l'économie
par exemple sur la question des
nationalisations
bref cette crise elle signe aussi une
mise en cause assez radicale de la
mondialisation car on voit bien que
c'est la notion de souveraineté
nationale
de souveraineté sanitaire de
souveraineté dans le domaine de la santé
pour commencer qui est à l'oeuvre et
vous savez on ne reviendra sans doute
pas en arrière
une fois cette crise terminée merci
jacques en tout cas pour votre analyse
qui donne à réfléchir merci à vous et à
bientôt
ou peut-être pas bientôt d'ailleurs sur
ce plateau toujours merci parce qu'ils
paient effectivement mais voilà on a on
est quand même votre chronique c'est
parfait comme ça
merci à vous y allez prenez soin de vous
mais malgré la pandémie plus de dix
mille personnes se sont réunies hier au
bangladesh pour une grande prière
collective
un rassemblement qu'on n'aimerait pas
forcément voir en ce moment pour être
honnête alors que le pays connaît son
premier décès est pose du coronavirus
officiellement 14 personnes sont
infectées mais les autorités suspectent
plus de cas en raison du faible nombre
de tests disponibles les écoles et les
universités sont fermées les
scientifiques redoutent particulièrement
la progression du virus dans ce pays de
160 millions d'habitants et pour cause
des milles
de dix mille ressortissants font
régulièrement des allers et retours à
l'étranger et nomen mesures contre le
coronavirus en israël également le
gouvernement enregistre les données des
personnes testées positivement aux
coronavirus l aide de la géolocalisation
sur leur téléphone les autorités peuvent
ainsi retracé le parcours de ces
personnes et ainsi retrouver celles
qu'elles ont pu contaminer
selon paul à slayer journalistes rt
international cette mesure n'est pas
nouvelle mais c'est bien la première
fois qu'elle est utilisée par des
citoyens ordinaires
telle est simple analyse oui c'est un
moyen fréquemment utilisé par la
sécurité intérieure pour trouver des
extrémistes et des terroristes dans le
pays
et si vous demandez aux israéliens la
plupart d'entre eux soutiennent cette
mesure mais la réponse est différente si
vous leur demandez si cette mesure peut
être utilisée sur des citoyens
ordinaires
permettez moi de souligner qu'israël
n'est pas le seul pays qui utilise cette
mesure en ce moment l'iran et la chine
ont également utilisé est le premier
ministre a déclaré que cette situation
appelle à des mesures de despotisme
il dit que c'est un moyen de lutter
contre le terrorisme pour la santé
publique
il appelle donc en fait la lutte contre
le coronavirus une lutte contre le
terrorisme et c'est ainsi qu'il se
justifie
on termine par ces images de solidarité
c'est là des français à leur fenêtre
comme si encore une fois aujourd'hui on
la voyait déjà hier dans le 20e
arrondissement de paris
ils ont remercié par d
ils sont
des personnels de santé qui luttent
contre le port une habilleuse effet
observé depuis le début du camp qu'ils
m'ont un peu partout dans le pays
[Applaudissements]
et c'est la fin de cette émission un peu
écourtée vous l'aurez compris un rt
comme toutes les chaînes d'ailleurs de
france modifie ses programmes en raison
de la crise du grenat virus qui comptera
évidemment les équipes excellente fin de
soirée à tous prochain point sur
l'actualité ce ne sera pas à 22 heures
comme d'habitude mais à 8 heures du
matin heure française mais vous pouvez
évidemment retrouver toutes nos
émissions
no votre caste sur notre site rt
france.com excellente fin de soirée à
tous
[Musique]
sa ville écrit des livres et ça c'était
un peu votre vote secret votre ambition
secrète catonné actrice à un moment
donné il faut faire autre chose il faut
prendre la parole
il faut dire que je et comment mieux
qu'en écrivant votre livre raconte
l'histoire donc de vania vassia de leur
fille sonia by sonia c'est un peu vous